el mundo mira con preocupación el golpe
de estado en sudán donde las fuerzas
armadas dirigidas por el general
abdelfatah burn detuvieron al primer
ministro y declararon el estado de
emergencia la onu instó a la liberación
de todos los funcionarios arrestados por
love of the change la detención ilegal
del primer ministro de los funcionarios
del gobierno y de los políticos es
inaceptable y contraviene el documento
constitucional y la alianza fundamental
para el éxito de la transición
el secretario general de la liga árabe
ahmed abul gheit pidió a todas las
partes que respetaran los acuerdos de
transición sobre el reparto de poder
entre civiles y militares y por su parte
la unión africana pidió la reanudación
inmediata del diálogo entre civiles y el
ejército mientras la unión europea
sostuvo que hay que evitar la violencia
y el derramamiento de sangre con la
liberación de los líderes políticos
la unión europea está muy preocupada por
el hecho de que al parecer las fuerzas
militares de sudán hayan puesto al
primer ministro abdalá a ambos bajo
arresto domiciliario así como por la
detención de otros miembros de la
dirección le instamos a su rápida
liberación estas palabras de las que
eeuu se ha hecho eco tras afirmar que
las acciones de los militares en sudán
están en franca oposición con la
voluntad del pueblo sudanés y con sus
aspiraciones de paz
washington está suspendiendo los fondos
destinados al país y sin cualquier
cambio en el gobierno de transición por
la fuerza arriesga la asistencia en
nuestra relación bilateral más amplia a
la luz de los acontecimientos
eeuu suspende la asistencia mientras
dentro del propio continente sudáfrica
dijo que estaba profundamente preocupada
por cualquier intento de socavar la
transición política de ciudad